en termes de consommation la situation
est compliquée car si l'état nous
demande de sortir le moins possible
il faut bien faire ses courses pour
certains afin d'éviter de prendre un
risque trop grand en se mélangeant à la
foule dans des supermarchés où souvent
les distances de sécurité ne sont pas
tout à fait respecté entre les clients
la solution de la livraison à domicile
s'impose mais en plus de se faire livrer
des courses beaucoup profitent de la
livraison à domicile pour se faire
livrer des produits qui ne sont pas de
première nécessité jeu accessoire
cadeaux la livraison à domicile tourne à
plein régime sauf que voilà
si cette solution est simple et rapide
elle est loin d'être sans risques si
avec les mesures de sans contact les
livreurs dépose les colis et s'en vont
immédiatement pour ne pas croiser les
clients c'est précisément pour ces
livreurs que la situation est critique
obligé de travailler et d'entrer en
contact avec leurs collègues et
transporter des colis de la main à la
main ses employés souvent sous payés
sont aujourd'hui pris en otage de même
pour la livraison de plats à domicile
très courue dans les grandes villes qui
là encore n'est pas indispensable si
certains encouragent la livraison pour
les personnes les plus à risque il
indique dans le même temps qu'il faut
limiter au maximum d'avoir recours à ces
pratiques la justice vient d'ailleurs
d'interdire le géant de la vente en
ligne amazon de livrer des produits non
essentiel pendant le confinement en
france une décision de justice inédite
qui interroge alors faut-il arrêter les
livraisons
alors on a avec nous grégory caret donc
directement c'est que choisir et merci
que le groupe parce que je peux vous
dire on va avoir besoin besoin de vous
en ce moment et après la crise du
coronavirus que je pense que tous les
tous les consommateurs - vous vous
appelez vous allez vous être assailli je
peux vous dire de coups de fil ou de
demandes
ça a déjà commencé ou par grégory ouioui
on a des demandes alors là ça concerne
plutôt les annulations de voyages et
comment se faire rembourser
bien sûr un flou artistique alors c'est
vrai que pour le consommateur êtes
extrêmement important merci en tout cas
d'être avec nous est ce que vous
comprenez ici les chéris que le tribunal
de nanterre 10 amazon d'arrêter de libre
et vous avez vu la mode la mode je crois
que c'était que c'était combien millions
un million contre 1 million par million
par jour 1 million pas vraiment d'amande
grégory donc je pense que ça les a
calmés amazon oui oui exactement
alors la condamnation c'est parce qu'en
fait amazon a méconnu une obligation de
sécurité de ses salariés c'est un
syndicat de salariés en fait qui a porté
plainte
donc là ils ont ils ont l'obligation de
réévaluer les risques s'agit pas de
mettre ses salariés en danger
donc ils ont décidé de fermer tous leurs
entrepôts pendant pendant cinq jours
donc on ne l'aura pas a priori de
livraison amazon est un fournisseur
important pour les consommateurs mais
c'est c'est cette fermeture et risquent
d'impacter le portefeuille des français
quand même non alors c'est vrai que
c'est un acteur important et donc va y
avoir une blague mission importante de
l'offre et tout ce concert soit il ya
une diminution de l'offre et à une
augmentation des prix
on l'a observé il ya il ya quelques
semaines déjà vous savez quand il ya eu
la mise en place du confinement il ya
beaucoup de commerçants qui ont arrêté
leur activité et face à ça il ya aussi
beaucoup de consommateurs ont eu besoin
de s'acheter des produits qui n'étaient
pas sans nécessairement des produits de
première nécessité il ya eu les
imprimantes d'ailleurs tous ceux qui
sont des jeunes enfants sur le rendu
compte qu'il fallait des imprimantes
c'est pas mal de choses alors bastien
voilà et là qu'est ce qui s'est passé il
ya eu moins d'offres et puis d'un seul
coup il ya eu des pluies surtout qui se
sont envolés au plus risquent
effectivement qui est actif grégory en
tant que soutien parce qu'on a parlé d'
hannah fois des prix dans les grandes
surfaces et il y en a beaucoup
disait que sa vie non mais bon augmenté
à panier égal pendant la crise du
coronavirus il disait que mine de rien
leur course leur coûter beaucoup plus
cher y en avait qui disaient non c'est
parce qu'on prenait plus de choses et y
en a qui disaient non à pagny égal je
peux te dire que ça vaut plus cher
grégory est vous qui êtes spécialiste
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire si vous
avez fait une étude là dessus sur les
supermarchés sur les produits vraiment
de première nécessité papier toilette
unis voilà les produits voilà qu'on est
les premiers trucs pour manger des oeufs
des trucs voilà est-ce que vous avez vu
une augmentation dont les grandes
surfaces ou pas du tout oui alors c'est
quelque chose qu'on étudie donc on va
étudier ça alors on sait braz et
spécifiquement sur sur les sites drive
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas envoyé nos
enquêteurs dans les magasins c'est pas
le moment d'aller se promener en forêt
tu reçois donc là on a utilisé les les
drives alors faut savoir thé bahreïn y
en a beaucoup en france c'est énorme
c'est à peu près quasiment le même
nombre sur le manque de l'hypermarché de
supermarchés alors on a relevé les prix
on a observé les plys des prix avait
évolué par rapport aux semaines juste
avant le confinement alors il ya de bien
des bas et il ya il ya une règle un peu
subtile si vous regardez les offres
produits par produits les commerçants
c'est vrai n'ont pas augmenté les plus
si vous prenez le papier toilette de la
marque intel aujourd'hui par rapport à
il ya deux semaines les prix dont on
parle et voilà mais en revanche
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est qu'en rayon
il ya eu beaucoup de pénurie et si vous
allez en magasin vous allez constater
qu'il ya des pénuries et balla vous
allez acheter finalement ce qui reste en
rayon qui reste en rayon c'est un peu
plus cher c'est à dire que en effet les
commerçants nos 10 ans n'a pas augmenté
les prix et les gens nous disent moi
j'ai plus cher en tickets de tesla les
deux ont raison et les gens ils ont été
obligés de changer de substituer des
achats d'autres il était plus chère
s'est produit alors grégory juste est ce
que est ce qu'on doit faire des stocks
folle sur les produits de première
nécessité ou bien on en a pas besoin
yahia c est ce que les consommateurs
doivent aller faire des stocks ou pas du
tout alors non il s'agit pas de il
s'agit pas de faire des stocks parce que
faire des stocks c'est à dire acheter
plus que ce dont on a besoin
vagba créer des pénuries et les pénuries
bah c'est pas c'est pas agréable pour
ceux qui passent derrière et puis en
plus ça et ça crée une inflation sacré
une salle immense les prêts exactement
donc il faut acheter de façon
raisonnable il faut essayer alors c'est
vrai que il faut essayer de sortir un
peu moins souvent mais général
les courses en supermarché en moyenne on
y va une fois par semaine donc dans ce
cas là pas besoin de stocker les
professionnels disent qu'il n'y a pas de
risque de pénurie à court terme
maintenant on va falloir en effet que
tous les professionnels se remette en
place pourrait recréer des produits là
les règles vont un peu changé on voit qu
amazon par exemple voient peut s'arrêter
pour se remettre aux nouvelles normes
pour la vision de la diffusion du
coleader et ben merci grégory caret nous
avoir donné ces infos pour nos
consommateurs qui nous regardent merci
beaucoup grégory merci nous rappelle
vous êtes directeur de l'observatoire
ufc que choisir et c'est important
voilà qui nous donne des réponses pour
nos consommateurs merci beaucoup grégory
merci d'avoir été là ce genre de dire
quelque chose oui mon genre mais oui
parce que moi j'ai été regardé pas mal
les commentaires des fronces il a quand
même beaucoup qui sont si masse de 2 de
cette décision du tribunal en disant que
ça à cause de direction d'un syndicat et
banale gens qui voyaient privés sont
confinés ils sont prisés plein de choses
alors amazon et non plus avait déjà pris
les mesures mais il est de bon ton de
taper sur amazon en ce moment mais il ya
plein de jeunes les produits bell son
nom est censé être aimé dire quoi quand
vous êtes confie nick des enfants un jeu
de société c'est important pour le
confinement
quand vous êtes sur la campagne des
livres c'est important y a pas que la
nourriture ou autre chose comme ça c'est
de notre fils à rester les livraisons
vont encore un navire russe non à 72%
dons qui sont assez d'accord avec vous
jean michel maire matthieu delormeau et
fall oui alors déjà juste un tout petit
mot sur l'augmentation des prix
effectivement un nouveau mensonge aussi
un puisque celui qui aurait pas de
pénurie il y en a c'est pour ça qu'on a
acheté des produits plus chers mais sur
amazon là où je rejoins jean mi c'est
aberrant effectivement qu est ce qu est
un produit de nécessité ou de panne ou
pas de première nécessité pendant le
confinement occuper ses enfants faire en
sorte que les gens restent locales c'est
la première nécessité et puis du coup je
pose une autre question j'ai peut être
que monsieur déjà partis mais quand
expliqué que cdiscount par exemple pour
pas citer de marque
oui peuvent continuer de livrer alors
nous explique que c'est parce que c'est
plein de plateforme qui réunit respecter
certaines mairies fine donc ils vont se
remettre en place
à part à bord et ça sera fait et ça ils
vont être fermées pendant cinq jours et
après ça vont pouvoir peut-être revenir
mais tout ça c'est du pipeau tout ça et
ce serait bien déjà qu'un masoni payent
leurs impôts
- d'accord et crémants comme ça y est
vous les laisserez geek parce qu'ils
passent à côté de la porte
je suis d'accord et alors là vraiment je
suis 100% d'accord avec toi amazon com
zones là ils ont menacé ils ont dit
qu'ils allaient avec la place cyril à
merveille on y paie pas ses impôts en
france non plus si on va la donne en
raison amazon il faut que trouver une
solution bah c'est pas possible
oui prenez ouais moi tu sais que tu es
un syndicaliste avis et je trouve normal
que le délégué syndical effet stop et
tout s'ils n'étaient pas à mesures de
sécurité maximales attention et doit
maintenant s'ils se remettent wahou
normes
amazon normal que là je suis d'accord
avec michel normal qu'ils repartent
parce que les produits de première
nécessité dans ce conte innoval il y
avait un peu le mal de produits de
première nécessité mais le syndicat qui
n'était pas d'aller y avait pas les
mesures que celui d'hier le qu'il est et
vous passez dans la zone qui pose un
colis de l'ivoire vous pensez qu'il
prend plus de risques une caissière plus
de risques année voire plus de risques à
routier plus de risques un facteur il
pose le coni devant la porte
on part ils croient pas autant de soin
jusqu'ici ils sont pas en danger